wow this guy looks like an assassin
what he can fly oh those wings are
pretty cool
here's a warrior maybe oh no way he can
also fly like an angel
wow this game looked very cool and
attractive
this game are very angel fly high and
shift the sky
oh excuse me gamers i was just enjoying
my favorite mobile game on my mobile
device
my honor 8x this is not sponsored it's
january everyone and you know what that
means especially for your youtuber
hey guys i'm gonna take a vacation
in january for no reason all the ads
disappear in january basically they go
december
and then it's just gone january is gone
the ads are gone do the crap dance
whatever okay it's gone
so instead of uh having ads on my video
i decided why don't we
watch ads wow what a great idea wow
you're gonna reiterate all your points
from your last video
okay you don't understand i found the
worst ads
i have seen in my entire life and it's
goddamn beautiful
people need to know about this i spent
my entire day just watching
so let's just jump into it i think
you're going to want to see this
my favorite ads no actually they're not
my favorite but they're
they're beautiful the goddamn beautiful
it's the mafia city ads
they make no sense these are the tommy
white
hands
oh yeah i'll download that game i can
play as it spirit but pewdiepie
means like thug in australian
boss he came to me again what do i do
what should i do should i use a knife or
a gun brick
always brick him and bricken will get
him every time brick
that guy looks like he came for
something else okay but my favorite one
that's how mafia works
that's how my view works that's how my
fear
works
is he gonna come in he came in on
himself
that's how mafia works there's just an
endless sea of these [ __ ] ads
and i cannot still understand
what the game is what is the game
all i know is that that's how mafia
works
and level 30 box damn he must be so rich
holy heck that's the mod from half-life
that's
what's her name alex are are they just
stealing mods from other games like
jesus christ
it's the more i find out about this game
the lifestyle can make sense out of it
here we have a level 15 boss leaving his
television
but then the level one came out of the
and he became level 50. oh now i get it
guys
that's how mafia works i get it now
[Music]
just blow it up right in front of you
why not it's goddamn
it's perfect this game is perfect what i
really appreciate about mafia city
is that they go out of their way to do
the experimental ads
they don't just hire some thought or i
don't know
we'll get into that later but for now
let's just appreciate this art piece
[Music]
all right pick the gun good choice
wow he picked gun make very damn
i don't know i don't know
how do i react to this did they just
shoot an egg they shot an egg
why
i'm so confused is this even a real game
i am so lost lately i'm so confused i'm
starting to question everything
like why does is this a real game or not
and i don't even want to know there's no
way this is not real
like what is bfi what is the power
struggle bar
and i'm free wait did it just say you
are with an aqua straw
that's it internet finally the
grammatical battle is over
it's not your it's not you are it's you
okay get it freaking right thank you
mafia city
for getting it freaking right now if you
want to give me that bread
to sponsor one of your videos i will
gladly oblige you think i'm joking it's
january it's freaking january
this is the video with the most game
play
i've seen so far in the trailer and
[Music]
it's a building shooting a building and
then the other building
says sneak attack let's
go get them and then a bunch of other
building comes up and they all shoot
fireballs
and that's how mafia works okay
that's how mafia works
who plays these games and why moving on
everybody to my second favorite game
where i'm saving the best for last
but this one is goddamn beautiful lords
mobile lords
mobile is the pinnacle of epic video
game moments
this is the reason why i am proud to be
a gamer this guy just invaded me and
he's not prepared for it
at all he should have scouted here's
what's happening
this guy has no idea what's going on
he's first of all
he's playing uh a mobile game at the
computer
because he's clearly just reading the
script instead
he doesn't have anywhere near enough
troops and his army composition is
garbage i was just about to say that his
army composition was garbage
how does he not see that does he not
play
lord's mobile
oh look it's another one of those where
a guy screams in the thumbnail
this again i i'm starting to question my
whole world view at this point
why are there so many goddamn guys
screaming in the thumbnail
abs on this play store who plays these
games
i never met anyone that plays these
games why do they all have five stars
i don't believe it this is not real
this is not reality something is wrong
okay
something is seriously wrong and i'm
getting concerned but all i know is
in this game you can have some epic bro
moment he's trying to attack us let's
just send in the cavalry
you think i might win this one judging
from what i'm seeing right now he has
way less troops than you
oh he's shooting arrows wait literally
going down why did they all die
you see how they're killing themselves
if you go to inverse arrow formation you
might have a chance against archers okay
this is what sun tzu was talking about
when he wrote art of war
this is he's looking at this going damn
i'm glad my knowledge my ancient wisdom
has been passed on
for the greater good of mankind thank
you lord mobile ads
thank you for putting use to my strategy
all right you think they might win
against the archers
yeah all right they're blocking with
their shields oh i love the dialogue it
just flows so naturally you think they
will win against my archers
you think they might win against the
archers yeah all right they're blocking
with their shields
oh i was just about to say that as well
they are blocking with their shields
what's gonna happen next i can't wait
wait we're actually winning
i told you let's go
oh my god i still love games
i love games i'm so proud to be a gamer
why are we still here
my favorite though my absolute favorite
game ads of all time you think you
couldn't beat mafia city
and the other one i don't remember their
names i don't want to remember them
but league of angels is has the top
notch
there's a cream of the pie whatever the
saying is
we got here oh oh
hotties everywhere oh my god there's
parties everywhere your clothes on
it's crazy it's crazy all the guys will
just stop and stare
look at that hottie damn this guy looks
like
zeus this guy looks like zeus he's not
wrong
he's not wrong i was just about to say
the same thing and i think that's why i
like this ad so much
because i was just about to say you may
think oh maybe it's desynced or
something so the next guy
that shows up looks like zoos so many
more characters no you want to have it
it's another girl
i can't tell if this guy is a dumbass or
if he's looking at another footage you
know it's either or
this guy looks like zeus just to be
clear here
just so we're on the same level of
understanding this company
paid this guy or paid someone else to
produce this video
to then pay more money to show this
video to people
just just so you guys are aware that
that's the level of production that went
into this that's
it the idea is to show this video to
people it's not one of those
where you kind of mess up and you're
like i hope no one sees that
they want people to see this
oh my god oh sorry sorry let's just this
is not
this is not uh league of angels but this
has to be my favorite one i've seen this
one before
but it's so goddamn beautiful want to
have a cool theme make your phone look
special
follow me shine bright like a diamond
let me show you some fantastic effects
we can control the pentagon
and it glows with moving icons
more transition effects
[Music]
i can't i cannot watch it i can't do it
i can't do it yes hey guys i'm here to
introduce to you
the new 3de what did she just say
it's a new launcher for my phone it's
cool have a look
oh wow is it a 3d spinner how does it
work it can customize icons into neon
and also organize apps into folders but
the coolest effect
is that you can control the spinner by
moving the icon
which then glows wow looks really cool
does it have any other function
yeah i like these little widgets i can't
okay
i can't this guy is my hero
just let it be known this man is my hero
sorry okay sorry sorry i
i completely forgotten the best ones
okay i hope you guys made it this far
because these are the best wow this guy
looks like an assassin he does he does
what
what he rides these wings are pretty
cool
yeah they are here's a warrior maybe oh
no way he can also fly like an angel he
can also fly like
angel she is flying my god
i also really appreciate legacy of
discord because
they also do the experimental ads they
go
way out and beyond here you have mike
and his
wife i'm mike and this is my girlfriend
he said hi to everyone hi oh
i don't know about you guys
is it just me or is mike's girlfriend
into me
i think she's hating on me she loves
playing with fire though check it out
can you give him a show yo pretty cool
right
yo and while we're at it
how about a kiss come on please
thank you if you want an angel as a
girlfriend
just come down to the game join us i'm a
gamer i'm back you know what screw books
gaming is saying it's at the gaming the
gaming i'm a gamer
i download games hey guys oh god it gets
harder
what is with the audio i thought my
audio was bad but jesus christ
hey guys i just saw this amazing game
commercial yesterday
i really want to share it with you guys
oh wait
look
commercial yesterday i really want to
share it with you guys
oh wait wait did you just cut a bullet
oh that's cool
what is happening double kill oh that's
crazy
her enthusiasm was just off the charts
that it stopped the recording
double kill oh that's crazy
dude that what is that double kill
i think i i think i figured it out i'm
not
i i'm starting to make sense of this
whole thing this whole phenomenon i
really i read this book on aa
and and basically what they said they
proposed this idea
that in the future ai will start produce
movies and video games and sell them to
make money
so you have ai under undercover
making video games producing them and
selling them
and also growing and multiplying at the
same time but they use games as examples
like skyrim and actually good games but
if you think about it
it makes way more sense that they would
produce games
that makes no [ __ ] sense but somehow
makes money ai has already happened it's
over for us
they've taken over through mobile ads
but i know your secret
hey i i know what you're up to i ain't
okay i'm scared i'm actually scared
catapult no destroyer that's cool
yeah okay here we go
[Music]
oh yeah yeah there's girls playing this
game
download i'm a gamer too guys
maybe i can meet a girl in my game all
right let's taunt these guys
see if i can get them to follow me i'm
done i'm done with this
no no fam i'm done i'm done okay
i've been hit up by a lot of these
gaming companies and i very rarely take
them just
mainly because the gameplay usually
isn't that interesting to watch
the way i judge accepting a brandel is
usually oh can i make an interesting
video out of it it's just something fun
i can make out of this
but usually games like this nah now you
can't
but they always come at you with this
insane amount of money the budgets that
these mobile games have
are insane they're crazy they pay
probably three or four times more than
normal brand deal would
but you know me mr integrity over here
i always say no because your game looks
like garbage but you know what
it's in january and i'm going to go
ahead and say
i'll take your brand deals i'll take
your money
please if you hit mafia city
lords mobile
angels of discord hit me up in the chat
let's talk
let's get this bread thank you very much
and i'll see you guys next time
bye you want pyramids
we got em oh you're into castles huh we
got you covered baby
you want some pets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant god damn it